well we on our way to Vegas and we
minutes-ish don't mess around with us
one is very happy because of a super
super hot super super cool at the same
time if you were freaking fool that's
all I got Google Maps is sending Quinn
and I on our first road trip together to
Las Vegas and we're gonna have a few
surprise stops along the way
you know while we were repping I
realized I don't know where I'm going I
might have to give you by the driver so
no no you're like I'm gonna navigate
better
I got it we are going it's four hours
and 22 minutes remember when used to try
get trucks to blow their horns I never
did that at all so distracting it's like
here's one coming up right now you said
you'd do this my way I don't want to do
it out you know yeah yeah I'll do only
if you want you got em you see does he
see you no good look over there on the
left you see that there's a Google Maps
billboard special burger treat on us
Peggy Sue's exit 191 take me there
navigate or all right we're on it's four
minutes away four minutes of free
burgers yay
hello hi how are you who are you
she's Peggy Sue is who she is my husband
and I opened this 28 years ago to kind
of reminisce about the places we used to
stop when we were young when we were
your age yeah I'm actually 50 I had a
lot of work done I'll tell you I've been
here 28 years and I never get tired of
talking to people
Thank You Sue and here's such a pleasure
you want to stay you just stay
tell him Peggy Sue said so Peggy Sue you
are such a charmer now he made you angry
because he like didn't clean his room
you're like what's up Richard Peggy Sue
I love you I think we really made a
connection no need to do this everyone
no she doesn't
been in a game a long time in so we got
to look at the second says world's
tallest thermometer for the world's
tallest thermometer be great for what
the world's largest giant with a cold
okay
if you wanna get me whenever you copy
quit any coffee quit on a coffee all
right I'll get coffee nearby world's
coldest coffee I will add this as a
stuff it's right near the thermometer
actually well I was like that's how hot
is it but the thermometer is right there
215 degrees
you found the world's coldest coffee
okay I'm gonna head straight to what
looks like an igloo hello I've entered a
mad scientist like this is like the
sexiest coffee ever
this mind if I get one large you think I
have one more yeah I really like coffee
right max what yeah really i back sweat
oh no ok it's going getting there though
do you boob sweat yep cool boobs are
super sweating what are their giant
versions of things if you want to see I
would love to see a giant block of
cheese what type of cheese though oh
mentioning them I want to see the
world's tallest baby oh um I'll guess uh
weenie guess so
there's guest very close to us but I
don't know if this is a mistake or not
but it says your price it says zero
dollars zero dollars and zero cents
do you want to try that one I mean yeah
I think we should go for that one oh man
that is a lot of cars this is definitely
for you guys I've always dreamed of
sexually pumping gas you know who
sexually pumps gas like ladies and
commercials weenie flip the script do I
look cute pumping this yeah zero zero
zero you see that Bam Bam Bam Bam
can I stand here and help other people's
guys now I'll be like the Santa Claus of
gasoline hey hey can i plug your gas
will you give me an emotion to pump your
gas with anything theater for
ah that's my butt look hey what's up oh
thank you I love this looks like a car
full of try girl loving happy Brit Oh
birthday
how shall I pop your gas slowly so
slowly okay oh I'm gonna say oh happy
birthday dear bye ladies
see I told you you were thinking Eugene
don't sexily pump gas in that's all they
wanted was me to sexually pump the gas
Hey yes baby yes yes go fakest go fake
it Oh go don't fake it uh we ran our way
oh that went on a second hey it looks
like we're heading towards a city Vegas
baby eunuch yeah you damn little no I
don't I don't either I don't like to
waste money potentially you know where
that money could go towards what a
buffet or drinks I'm saying right
anything short yeah yeah I've been
taking a road trip in a while yeah me
neither I'm glad it was with you
yeah same even though we're going to
Vegas for a trip just felt like a trip -
it was own journey yeah look at that
it's really cool this iconic right right
so there's the sign guys yeah you what
yeah that was like an adventure in
itself yeah and I think as one adventure
ends another one will begin so there's
only one thing left to do right yeah
party party party party Vegas Vegas
Vegas Thanks